le LIFI ou la transmission de données
par la lumière démonstration par exemple
ici
a de couleur ave des musiques
différentes on
déplacele une lumière ou une autre on a
des chans
[Musique]
différ le concept fonctionne un langage
binaire principe de be que
l'informatique c'est des
et se dit que si on éteint une lumière
c'est un zéro si on l'allume c'est un 1
si on fait ça très rapidement donc l'œil
humain ne le perçoit pas mais
l'informatique le comprend donc on peut
envoyer des données comme ça outre la
magie du procédé le LIFI a d'autres
avantages pas don d'électromagnétique
contrairement au wifi donc meilleur pour
la santé le LIFI se veut aussi
écologique puisque des lampes à LED sont
utilisé mise au point en 2012 par deux
professeurs de l'Université de
Saint-Quentin en yeline au travers de la
start-up oletcom les pous possibilités
du LIFI sont infinies n'importe quel
domaine d'application peut y avoir
recours le particulier les musées mais
aussi l'industrie automobile pour des
moyens de sécurité par exemple on peut
imaginer un véhicule devant vous qui
freinerait si votre temps de réaction
n'est pas assez rapide les deux
véhicules donc communiquent grâce à leur
feu à l'aide avant et arrière et
permettra à votre véhicule de freiner en
cas de besoin la start-up est déjà en
relation avec deux musées de Liège en
Belgique pour remplacer les audioid
traditionnels par des tablettes
réceptives à la lumière pour informer
les
visiteurs